Speaker 1: All right, let's let's keep talking
to people. Why don't we maybe against my better
judgment? Let's go to Eric from Cancun. Eric, from
Cancun, has delivered some of the best calls we've
ever had and also some so atrocious I've had to
cut them early. Eric, what's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: Hey, David, and first, I want to
apologize about the last time we called. And the
thing is that it wasn't out of bad faith, it was
out of not knowing how to put my ideas into words.
I do apologize for the last time we've
called. And the thing I want to talk about,
can I talk about my autism, my for a.
Speaker 1: If you would like. Yeah,
and remember, you know, we have a lot of
people waiting to chat. So ideally, if you
have a question, that would be the ideal thing.
Speaker 5: OK. And I want to clear out the doubts,
so fancy boxes because I want to tell you that it
doesn't. I do think the vaccine. I was born with
it and get some symptoms with it. It doesn't turn
me into a shapeshifting monster. Although we still
like this volume we see from X-Men, as it does,
is that I'm black of some emotional intelligence.
And have you seen the movie, have you seen the Big
Bang Theory for so long and like some corporate,
forgot where he goes through the door
and he notes, like this Benny, Benny,
Benny and some messages have some those guys
that ball of the teeth then have some emotions
assemble because they play the piano. Sometimes
I pretend to play the piano when I hear
a song. I like some very literal examples. If
you think of an electric plane, someone could
think of a Christmas tree. Maybe just me. Or
maybe for a is, but animals are brutally honest.
Have you seen the movie liar? Liar. I have
a wife. Again, the movie Liar, Liar. They
tell the truth without filter.
Speaker 1: Right. All right, well,
very good, Eric, I appreciate you calling
in, and we always love hearing from you.
Speaker 5: But trust me, if I say something
inappropriate is not that of bad faith,
and I apologize if I apologize, if I do.
Speaker 1: Well, you've never said anything
that I'm aware of in bad faith, Eric. Thank you.
Speaker 5: Kate, I wish to call you, Sally,
and tell you more about other things.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good. Now one thing,
Eric, I was under the impression that we don't use
the term Asperger's anymore because it refers to a
Nazi doctor. And so we just say low on the
autism spectrum, are you? Have you heard of that?
Speaker 5: No, because I do have Asperger's
and my called my psychiatrist told me that
it's okay if I use that term. OK, I'm.
Speaker 1: All right. Very good, Eric,
thank you all. Weather is good in Cancun today.
Speaker 5: And is right now, Renee, and all is
like a sound that but right
now is like it in some areas
where you live. Are you in Los Angeles, right?
Speaker 1: No, I will be in Los Angeles next week,
actually, but I'm in the northeast. All right,
Eric, thank you very much. Appreciate the call.
We love hearing from Eric from Cancun and glad
to hear that you were doing well. Let's go next
to Sam in New York City. Sam, you were on the air.
Speaker 3: Hey, thanks for taking my call. I just
want to get your take on the potential of
reintroducing what's it called earmarks
into bills, given how difficult it's been to
pass some of these major bills, the Democrats
have been trying to get through Congress and they
understand the potential to lead corruption. But
I feel like earmarks could be a good way to
get these bills passed if the Senate limit.
Speaker 1: No, I don't like it. You're making
it a pyrrhic victory. I understand the idea,
which is, you know, you start allowing for more
goodies in these bills and you'll get people to
support them. But I would I would consider
it a pyrrhic victory. It would be a victory
in which you do so much damage that do you really
come out ahead? I don't. I don't like it now. I
don't think we should go backwards.
Speaker 3: Even if it's like,
all right, maybe some edge after Joe
Manchin for, I don't know, million
Speaker 1: dollars or, you know, it's like a
lot of times those things aren't done at the
federal level anyway. I'm not sure it doesn't. It
doesn't strike me. I think the right way to do it
is elect a few more Democrats, you know?
Speaker 3: I guess my thought is that the
marginal cost of an earmark is way less than
the benefits of passing some of these bills
overall. So it's but I get what you're
saying if it is just a pyrrhic victory,
if it's going to lead to something that's sort
of inadequate. And of course, there's no point.
Speaker 1: I mean, the marginal cost of one
earmark might be small, but if you if you say,
let's just start handing out earmarks again,
it's not going to be just one that you're
exchanging for the bill, it's going to be
dozens, hundreds, whatever you know. Yeah,
I don't know anything else, Sam.
Speaker 3: No terrorists want to
get your take, thanks so much.
Speaker 1: All right. Appreciate
it there, Sam from New York City.
Great to hear from you, of course